Most of us in the western world expect judges
to wear a robe when they sit behind their
bench in a courtroom, and they usually do
not disappoint.
But we rarely think about how the long, usually
black, robe became the standard outfit for
the men and women who preside over criminal
and civil cases in the courtroom.
The tradition began about seven hundred years
ago in England.
Robes became the standard uniform for judges
in England during the reign of Edward II,
who ruled from 1327 until 1377.
At this point, they had already been the standard
garb for academics for over a century (see:
Why Graduates Wear Caps and Gowns), as well
as worn in other settings.
For instance, at this point, this type of
garb would also have been appropriate for
wear for a visit to the royal court, so a
judge wearing his robes outside of the courtroom
would not have been out of place.
The standard robes for judges at this point
came in three colors: violet for the summer,
green for the winter, and scarlet for special
occasions.
Judges often received the material for these
robes as part of a grant from the King.
The last mention of the green robes occurs
in 1534, and new guidelines dictating which
robes could be worn at certain times appear
in 1635.
The new guide suggested judges wear black
robes with a fur trim during the winter and
violet or scarlet robes that feature pink
taffeta for the summer.
Historians believe that the transition to
only black robes may have begun in the second
half of the 17th century in England.
But it is not known for sure what exactly
caused the switch, though a popular theory
ties the black robes to the mourning period
after the death of a monarch.
Some historians claim that the funeral of
Queen Mary in 1694 helped cement the already
worn black robes as the typical attire while
others point to the death of Charles II in
1685 as the start of that tradition.
Whatever the case, additional guidelines instructing
judges to wear black robes appeared in the
middle of the 18th century.
At that point, English judges typically wore
a scarlet robe with a black scarf and a scarlet
hood when presiding over criminal cases.
But for civil cases, they often wore black
silk robes.
When the judges in the American colonies presided
over legal proceedings, whether civil or criminal
cases, they carried over the English tradition
of wearing robes.
This topic produced debate between Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams after the colonists
won the American Revolution and formed their
own government.
Jefferson argued that American judges should
distance themselves from the traditions set
down by the English and wear only a suit in
court.
Adams, a lawyer, disagreed and wanted judges
to continue wearing the robes and wigs of
English judges.
A compromise ensued, with it being decided
that the new American judges should wear the
robe and not the wig.
Judges in the United States continue to wear
robes in the courtroom, despite the lack of
a rule requiring them to be worn.
Even in the Supreme Court of the United States,
there is no requirement that its justices
wear a robe in court.
Yet due to the tradition, and perhaps it being
something distinguishing from everyone else
in the courtroom, a mark of authority, judges
continue to wear them.
Judges have been wearing robes for over seven
hundred years, after all.
Former Associate Justice of the Supreme Court
Sandra Day O’Connor admits that wearing
the robe may simply be a matter of tradition,
but she likes what it symbolizes.
“It shows that all of us judges are engaged
in upholding the Constitution and the rule
of law…
We have a common responsibility.”
That is not to say that judges always wear
their robes or stick to the traditional black
robe.
Judge ShawnDya L. Simpson of Manhattan, New
York has admitted to forgoing the robe altogether
in favor of a lime green suit on occasion.
Even when she wears her robe, she does not
always fasten all the buttons on it.
She also occasionally accents her robe by
wearing a scarf or a necklace.
Justice Bruce Allen of the New York State
Supreme Court usually leaves off his robe
while sitting at the bench.
He generally only wears it when there is a
jury present in
the courtroom.